yes sir sup dude we're good how's it
going it's good good so you are like the
movie dreamy boyfriend example of what
people want in their real lives what is
that I just you know I think I think
people like to draw connections between
the character and the actor a lot yeah
you know but it's it's all love it I'm
super grateful for it right so this
movie around Valentine's Day but talking
to everybody about this this movie is
gonna be the sort of safe focal point of
the Valentine's Day date night for two
people who are dating maybe not yet in
love what else should happen around this
movie on that night you know man I think
I think the you should watch the movie
on the 12th and then do whatever it is
you're gonna do on the when you're you
know when you're not junior high and in
high school everybody has that movie
where they're like God why can't my life
be like the movies did you have that
movie did you have that movie when you
were younger where you're like god I
wish I was that I wish I was in that
that was my life really man I think I
think you know we do that a lot you're
right we really do make other people the
hero in our life movie really if I could
be like that person it'd be better if
mom whatever was this and truthfully man
I've always tried to make myself the
center of my story you know yeah that's
why I'm a narcissist
right fair enough but no it's important
that you know there's a there's a
there's a there's a strength that comes
with being like I'm in control of my
life and I can make changes to myself to
benefit my life in the life of others I
have to talk to about he-man real quick
because I know that Jordan does a voice
on Shira yes
okay I'm actually not doing I speak
about let me have it
have there been conversations about all
because the chemistry between you three
is awesome yeah but all of you doing
something he suggested Fantastic Four oh
um dude look I will work with those two
on anything yeah that must be a
superhero movie that would be good and I
know you can't say it but have you seen
the outfit that you will be one yeah
because that has to be the greatest
motivation to work out and go say but
please tell me that's the motivation
that's a dangerous thing to have to wear
man you should be working out because
it's healthy that's what it is not
because of the fur do something with the
body stretch yoga so that's it and what
do you hope people get out of this movie
what do you hope they take a well I
really like you know one of the biggest
themes in this film is the fact that you
can have a concrete belief in something
it's nights for the promise right the
movie starts for the promise you have a
concrete belief in something and that
concrete belief can dissolve and it ends
with the breaking of that promise but it
can be better you know if you have this
concrete belief that dissolves and yet
it enriches your life
that's a little bit of a different story
than the one we're told right you always
seeking something that's gonna remain
the same well sometimes things don't
remain the same and sometimes that's
better
see this is why people shriek when you
walk on screen into it stuff like that I
saw it last night
thank you very much appreciate it